[موسيقى]
كلكم من يجي العيد
تتعادلون بعيد سعيد
بس حوراء
ابدا مو سعيد
خليني اقول لكم ليش عيدي كان مساعد خلني
ارجع وياكم وقبل اسبوع من عيد 2005 بالضبط
عشان عمري خمس سنوات
ومثل اي بيت عراقي
ليتحضرون للعيد طلع والدي ورحت لحقته
ما اعرف شنو اللي صار
بس بلحظه فتحت عيني
شفت الدنيا بيضاء
طريقه عجيبه
وبتفكير الطفوله
رفعت راسي للسما
وتخيلت انه اني متت ويمكن اني بالجنه
ما كنت اسمع غير بس صوت عياط
اربع ايام لقيت نفسي نايمه باحد اسره
المستشفى
فاستوعبت انه اني انصابت خلال القصف اللي
صار واني شنو تلاحقه والدي
كنت اسمع امي
بصوت خافت
تقول يا ربي ليش اخذت فرحت بنتي مني
فاني عرفت
انه اني للاسف
بعد ما راح اقدر امشي على رجلي مره ثانيه
حيكون الكرسي المتحرك
رفيق حياتي
بعد رحله علاج دامت سبعه اشهر واخيرا
رجعت لبيتي بس اكيد هالمره مو مثل ما طلعت
هالمره اني ما امشي
بدت الصعوبات اللي واجهتني وواجهه اهلي
اولها انه شلون راح القى مدرسه تتقبل وضعي
فمن عمري سبع سنوات عرفت انه اني هواي راح
اعاني بحياتي
يعرف او يحس
شنو معنى طالبه بين كل المدرسه
ما تقدر تقوم على السبوره
او انه تقعد على حالها حال باقي صديقاتها
او انه تحيل العلم
كانت كل امنياتي اشيل جنودتي على ظهري
واروح المدرسه
حبي للعيد ولهفتي الى ماتت
صاروا من يقولون باكر عيد اني احسن
احلام حالها حال باقي البنات اللي بعمرها
بس انا احلامي كانت كلش بسيطه
اللي بعمري كانت تحلم تتخرج تشتغل بمهنه
يمكن هي تحبها
اني كانت احلى امنياتي واكبر احلامي
انه البس ملابس العيد واني واقفه
او انه العب بالمراجيح
كنت اتمنى اعيش الفرحه اللي يعيشوها
الاطفال اللي بعمري
وعلى هالحال
لحد ما اجتي سنه 2014
شاركت بنادي الرياضي
وعرفت انه اكو اسوا من حاله حوراء بهواي
وهنا قررت اغير حياتي وبشكل جذري وعرفت
شغله انه العاقه عمرها ما كانت بالجسد
لعاقه الحقيقيه هي عاقه العقل
بسنه 2017
شاركت بطولات
محليه واقليميه هوايه اليوم اني لاعبه
منتخب وطني حصلت على المركز الثالث في
بطوله اسيا من بين سبعه واربعين دوله
اسيويه مشاركه
كل يوم قبل ما انام
اقول يلا يمكن تصير معجزه واقعد الصبح
وانا ما ابي شي وارجع مره ثانيه وامشي على
رجليا
دائما كان عندي ايمان بربي قوي انه سبحانه
وتعالى
اختارني القوتي وصبري ونتالي هالصبر حيكون
عوض من رب العالمين كلش حلو
وعلى هالحال لحد ما اجتي سنه 2018
رافقني اخويا برحله علاج الاربيل وقال لي
حوراء تعالي خلي انزل صوره وياك على الفيس
حتى اراوي الضابط مالتي انه انا رايح وياك
رحله علاج وموده اسخن
فطلب من اصحاب الدعاء
بهالاثناء شافها الصوره ولد اسمه حيدر
فما اعرف انا شنو اللي صار
بس يقول اخوي انه ورا ما رجعنا من اربيل
حيدر تقدم للزواج واخويا رفضا ورا اسبوع
رجعوا تقدم لي للزواج وهم رجع اخويا رفضه
وعلى هالحال خمس مرات والمده سنه كامله
يطلب ايدي للزواج ويلاقي نفس الرفض سنه
2019 اخويا فتح الموضوع وياي
وانا المره الاولى كلش كنت مستغربه ملحته
بهالطريقه بس حيدر ما فقد الامل تدور عليه
على حساباتي بالسوشيال ميديا لحد ما القى
حسابي على الانستغرام
طبعا انا كنت اتجاهله بكل مسجد الزين الا
انا فد يوم دز لي رساله كلش طويله
يعترف لي بيها بحبه الي
حالي بنيه
[تصفيق]
ضعفت قدام هاي الرساله واستاذنت امي انه
اجابه فقالت ماما براحتش اللي تشوفيه صح
سويه
فجاوبته بقناه تواصل الفتره
اللي انصدمت بيه انه حيدر الاكثر من سنه
كامله يطلب ايدي للزواج
هو ما يعرف انه انا على كرسي متحرك
فيقول اني من دريت كلش انصدمت انه شلون
البنيه اللي احبها هيك وضعها زين اوكي
شلون راح اواجهها اهلي بالموضوع شنو حتكون
رده فعلهم
فبعد يوم كامل من التفكير اتقنت انه اني
صرت اقول لنفسي مثلا يعني لو بعد الزواج
وانا حيدر تعرضت لاي حادث انت راح تتركيني
فاكيد لا وباليوم الثاني وبدون اي تردد
رجعت وطلبت ايدك الزواج من اخوك
شلون ممكن يكون كل هالحب انخلق مجرد صوره
على الفيسبوك
اكيد الحياه مو كلها ورديه بالبدايه اهله
واقرباء رفضوا بحكم وضعه يعني
بس لهسه اتذكر كلام والده شهيد اللي قاله
اله قبل ما يستشهد بثلاثه اشهر بس الله
يرحمه بابا حيدر انت حر باختياراتك اذا
تحس نفسك حتكون سند لهاي البنيه وتقويها
فتقدم لها وامشي بطريقك واذا كان حبك الها
مجرد نزوه فابتعد عنها ولا تاذيها
شنو اللي يقهر
من فتره الخطوبه وانا اسمع نفس الكلام
انه انت شلون راح تتزوجها
شرح تنظف بيتك شلون تغسل لك المواعين شلون
راح تهتم بيك الاهم من كل هذا شلون ممكن
تخلف لك طفل وتكون ام بس اوكي رغم كل
هالحكي حيدر ما دار بال واجو وجاب اهله
وتقدم لي بعشرين عشرين الشهر الثالث
[تصفيق]
وتقدم لي بشهر الثالث واتذكر لي هسه كان
يوم حلو وخطوه جديده انه نسبت بيها حبنا
للكل ونشوفهم انه ماكو شي مستحيل اول طلعه
لنا بعد العرس قررنا نمشي مسافه ثلاثه
كيلو متر واحنا ايد بايد وقدام الناس كلها
حتى نشوفهم
[تصفيق]
مستحيل والحب اقوى من كل شيء بس الصدمه
كانت نظرات الناس اللي مليانه تعجب وحيره
والكلام اللي هم يتعاد دائما وحتى من
المقربين شلون تزوجتي شلون حتى تنظفين
بيتك شلون حتككونين ام ما اخفيكم بدايتها
الكلام بالنسبه لي كان كلش مؤذي بس بدعم
وكلام حيدر اللي كان يحفزني وبطريقه عجيبه
يوقف قدامي الكل ويقول مرتي ما بيها عيب
تشتغل وتنظف وقايمه ببيت اذا فديهم حوراء
ما قدرت تسوي كلها الشغلات اسويهن اني
بمكانها
[تصفيق]
اكثر كلمه احبها منه يقول اني رجلك ورجلج
اذا فد يوم كان الكرسي ماكو يمش فلا
تهتمين اني اصير رجليناتك انت بس قولي وين
تريدين تروحين
[تصفيق]
انت بس قولي وانا اوديك وين ما تريدين مره
من المرات كان فرع بيتنا بيتبلط فقررنا
كلياتنا كعادت نطلع
فللاسف السياره ما قدرت تجي لباب البيت
وهي عائلتنا قوه قدرت توصل للسياره وهنا
الحكي دائما ينعاد حوراء شلون راح توصل
للسياره والطريق مكسر وما راح تقدر تمشي
هي والكرسي فهذا بدون ما يجاوب اي احد
حطنا على كرسي وشال الكرسي مالتي المتحرك
هو
ثلاث دقائق اجوا وقال لهم ترى مرتي ما
تحتاج تمشي انا اشيلها مثل الاميرات
[تصفيق]
يا ربي عن احساس وشعور هاللحظه هنا بالضبط
عرفت انه انا باليوم اللي انصابت بيه رفعت
راسي للسماء كانت رساله من رب العالمين ما
فهمت هلا بهاي اللحظه انه الله سبحانه
وتعالى عوضني باجمل هبه بالدنيا اليوم
بعد 17 سنه من الاصابه
حوراء زوجه الاحر رجل بالعالم
نهايه عشرين عشرين شهر 12 وانا اسوي
فحوصاتي بالمستشفى
دكتوره قالت لي انت حامل
[موسيقى]
شنو اني حامل معقوله هنا مشاعري كلش ضاربت
بين افرح بين احزن بين ابكي
اشوف بس حيدر من الفرحه
بالضبط سبحانه وتعالى زرع الداخلي روح
وصرت ام
وكلت نمره علي وقالوا شلون راح تجيبين
الطفل هم نفسهم جوي وباركولي
بعد 17 سنه من الاصابه
حوراء الزوجه اللي احر رجل بالدنيا وام
الاجمل طفل بالعالم اريد اوضح لكم شغله
انه اصعب شي
بالنسبه لي وكل ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه هي
نظراتكم ونظرات المجتمع اللي تحسسنا دائما
بالاستصغار لازم تعرفون شغله انه سبحانه
وتعالى اذا ياخذ شي فيعطيه هواي اشياء
حلوه ببداله الانسان اللي عنده اعاقه
بجسمه ترى ما جاء من الفضاء كلنا يا اما
ضحيه حرب وقتل يوم عندنا عاقه ولاديه كل
ذنبنا انه احنا انولدنا ببلد حكام يموتون
بالخراب اليوم
كلكم انتم تمثلون مجتمع كامل تخيلوا كم
شخص من ضمن احصائيه اربعه مليون معوق
عراقي قاعد بالبيت يخاف يطلع يخاف يواجه
نظرتك وكلامك ممكن حتى عدم تقبلك الى رجاء
اتمنى تكون رسالتي وصلت وبوجودنا نسبه انو
الدنيا بها مل احنا نكمل المجتمع خلونا
نحب بعض خلونا نتقبل بعض شكرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شيلها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]